welcome to this video play morning star
from the US hmm can't do something else
okay hmm I could transpose to the cow
carnal yeah maybe do that huh quick g6
that some quite uncommon you know I
don't know maybe it's an idea to on
prepare quick a bishop age six at some
point he needs to play Knight f6 we're
like here jack how so okay if he M carry
yet he actually does castle haha I
thought that h4 h5 is bit dangerous
maybe I'm I'm seeing this don't see this
correctly okay okay he might play you
five of course but still if I go h4
Bishop g4 maybe now I can you play 95
against that okay yes but I'm taking it
right
check young and what now actually let's
let's say just for a moment Bishop b5
hmm I wonder kill King King take what
the King Bishop takes Knight takes rook
takes yeah I'm very I'm well-developed
yeah I don't know yeah I don't I don't
know at both good problem look you want
this rook da check so I'm going to to
grab the bishops in and now may be here
controlling d5 l'd intending rookie when
I rookie Amanda I'm going to play his
there this is back rank meet business
nice d7 does even root checks I know
that's not unfortunately rook takes
takes Bishop takes check king edge aight
Bishop d7 and then rook d8 okay so i
must be content with just just the pawn
not bad doc of course oh no i've got
rookie six yeah yeah how is he going to
hand unpinned this Bishop g5 is a threat
yeah I played really quickly but it does
not help a feeling completely lost on
move 19 yeah just a piece cannot you
cannot save it Bishop g5 from is dead
lack resigns yeah I me five as I guess
simply not play along I don't I mean
black black seems to be in some danger
here with the h5 but each 5s is probably
not not not really a generally a
playable news yeah the rookie one is
also not bad but ok this is this should
be good for some advantage and now this
yeah that's already tricky he can play
here and this is a bit bit tougher check
yeah what this is at least not losing
material why does is clearly better
because of the structure and the better
minor piece and the king
um it was tougher than the game though
this is just flat out flat out there
probably already winning I mean it's the
pawn and everything else is also in
whites favor better minor piece better
activity but this losses get to be add
more material now yeah I know I know I'm
playing too slowly but this is not
helping just dashing out some moves
enter and be be lost like in 15 moves
alright thanks for watching